Misao lokove filozofije
I isticanje opštih odredova.
To je empirizam koji metafizicira.
I to predstavlja uobičajeni put unakama.
Ovim Hegelovim rečima
o Lokovoj filozofiji,
koji je napisao u svojoj istoriji
filozofije, započinjemo današnju emisiju.
Poštovani slušalci, u današnjoj emisiji
razgovaramo sa Mašanom Bogdanovskim,
docentom na Filozofskom
fakultetu u Beogradu.
Dobrodošli na gozbu.
Hvala. Hvala.
Razgovaramo o filozofiji Johna Locke,
o njegove epistemologiji,
ali i o epistemologiji religije.
Ali recite nam pre svega toga,
zašto je uopšte John Locke
značajan za istoriju filozofije,
odnosno kako biste vi odredili taj značaj?
Svakako da najveći značaj leži u tome
da je Locke začetnik modernog empirizma.
Empirizma onako kako ga nalazimo
u britanskoj školi tog filozofska.